what's up everybody I'm Greg Miller and
I'm here in Maryland and for access
games to find out all about civilization
six is civilization six the best one yet
no pressure civilization six builds on
everything we've done before this is the
best one yet yes or no yes that's what I
like to hear what we've done with this
is taken just the best of what we had
passed version of civilization we
brought forward all the great systems
that are going to look play with before
and then pout a lot more on top of that
it's really exciting to have a chance to
kind of put our own stamp on the series
how do you come into civilization six
wanting to tweak things change things
but not change it into something
completely different where people are
alienated we have a role at for access
you can add thirty three percent new
stuff thirty-three percent stuffed you
tweak but the last third should stay
pretty much exactly the same you know if
it ain't broke don't fix it what's the
most interesting aspect for you i would
say it comes down to the core tenets of
a game which is unstacking the cities in
cf5 and sieve games all the buildings
and all the sort of economy stuff you
have in your city is all kind of crammed
into this city center tile the idea with
districts that Ed had was to take some
of that and put it out on the map and so
each city kind of takes on its own
personality so it's very clear what that
city does you can see I have a library
have university or have a temple it
changes just about everything every time
you plop down a settler you're not just
looking at the resources they're looking
at everything around it because your
city get specialized based on what
you're seeing with a map not just
aesthetically but in terms of the
gameplay I'm reading the map in a way
that I have never done before we have
chosen our leaders this time in order to
come up with the people who are the
biggest personalities we love having
Teddy Roosevelt as our American leader
welcome to the United States of America
we have a whole new diplomatic system
for our leaders so that they can bring
those personalities into the game and we
call that the agenda system
look at what that character did in
history and so Roosevelt it is the big
stick diplomacy policy he was going to
build up the American military to be
strong enough that it was just like
hands off of the Americas he looks at
the continent around him and if anyone's
mucking around starting wars there
you're on his list we've talked a lot
about you know civilization six is doing
this it's gonna be great it's gonna be
great all these things are gonna be
great we get it but like what I want to
know is what is the riskiest thing
you've done we've rebuilt a gaming
engine entirely we have all these things
working and civ 5 and we're just like
out the window and it actually has
worked out well enough and when we get
to talking about mod ability people are
gonna go nuts with how much power we're
gonna put in place see if I came out
critically acclaimed everybody likes it
but they're like wow I feel like I'm
using military more than I've ever using
diplomacy and then as the expansion's
comes out it feels like you guys are
addressing those concerns is that how
you guys develop based on what people
are saying and seeing how people play in
game and move it all together that way
we absolutely spend more time than the
fans think reading this for cutting a
hard cut you guys crying at the care
what is the secret to civilization the
fact that it's been around 25 years the
way that it just spans throughout time
allows just a limitless amount of ideas
to be bolted onto it and have it work
and become a whole new game while
keeping that same foundation it's just
an amazing amount of stuff you can do
with it civilization 6 comes out october
21st 2016 until next time it's been our
pleasure sir
we're a very collaborative team here we
spent a lot of time concept and I get
ideas from the art team I take them to
the design team and we just go back and
forth that's why everybody likes her
games I think